when you talk to people they say what
are you fooling around with those things
for silent films were jerky ludicrously
acted badly photographed they're just
curiosities and particularly irritating
to me was the badly photographed because
that you could not hold against them
right from Lumiere they would not
absolutely superb in their original
prints and it was the laboratories not
caring thinking it's an old film what
can you do with it that ravaged them and
made them look so he is when talkies
came in producers were very anxious that
there should be talk his and only
talkies in the future and there was a
great number of people who loved silent
films and some of them started making
one real shorts with hokey commentaries
honky-tonk music speed adapt image and
using the very earliest most primitive
films and some of them were very funny I
hate to admit and a generation was
brainwashed into thinking that was what
silent films were like and they went on
being shown well into the forties and
fifties news theaters in England we
always used to see these Richard things
and it's ironic that some films only
survived because they were shot down to
15 minutes
I can't think actually of a big American
director who didn't work in the silent
days or wasn't brought up in the silent
days so you could you could meet any of
them and and when they came to England I
used to get in touch with them even
Richard Thorpe who turned up to have a
great reverence for DW Griffith for whom
he'd been an extra Andrew stone turned
out to be a fun collector mad about
Norma Talmadge had been making pictures
in the silent days
but people like Hitchcock and and Wyler
and all those were silent film makers
Alfred Hitchcock was asked for his 10
favorite films of all time and nine of
the most silenced